[Music]
welcome to pftot on yahoo sports peter
king and mike florio reviewing some of
the biggest news in the national
football league and the big news on
tuesday came from carolina where owner
david tepper decided to move on from
coach ron rivera and now the question
becomes beyond who the next coach will
be
what does it mean for quarterback cam
newton peter king we know cam newton is
injured he reportedly has had surgery on
that foot that knocked him out after
week two and he hasn't been back
uh what do you think happens long term
with cam newton in carolina or elsewhere
well mike i think a lot of people are
going to just assume that uh that ron
rivera if he ends up somewhere with a
quarterback need in 2020
uh that he will want to bring
cam newton with him
but i don't know that and i don't have
any inside information on this but i
don't
i don't think you should assume that
that is an automatic for for a couple of
reasons
i mean we don't know what cam newton is
as a quarterback anymore i go back to
training camp last year when i talked to
cam newton and he said hey listen i am
in the process and i'm paraphrasing of
becoming a new quarterback i'm going to
play a little bit different you know i'm
i'm sort of morphing into a new kind of
quarterback now and we'll see where it
leads us and i'm fine with that i don't
have to be the superman guy who's always
running the ball and all that
so
now if you're
if you've now gone through another
season in 2019 where basically it's a
total washout cam newton barely plays
and he's never healthy so you don't have
any idea what kind of quarterback is
going to take the field in 2020 in cam
newton because both 18 and 19 were
washouts 18 he was hurt the whole year
so
i don't know what cam newton is and the
cam newton who takes the field at age 31
next year
i i don't if i'm ron rivera do i want to
cast my fate with cam newton not knowing
really
who he is or what he's going to be next
year
and i think that with the panthers and
it reminded me of the situation with the
colts there becomes i think a certain
amount of fatigue for the organization
for the fan base for really anyone
connected to the situation constantly
worrying about the quarterback is he
healthy can he stay healthy how do we
have to change our offense to ensure
that he'll be healthy meanwhile he never
is healthy and this year for cam newton
it was so much of the shoulder the
shoulder the shoulder and then the foot
injury happens and that original foot
injury looked like it wasn't that big of
a deal so even though he's only 31 the
fact that he has
played with such physical reckless
abandon throughout his career i think it
does raise questions about whether or
not it's time to move on it's a very
tradable contract that there's a team
out there that looks at its quarterback
situation and says hey we'll welcome
some cam newton fatigue because he's a
hell of a lot better than who we have
and that's why i think rivera could be a
wild card because if you have a team
that's already thinking man we'd like to
get cam newton and we're going to change
coaches if rivera helps deliver cam
newton maybe that is a factor that
benefits rivera but peter as you said
maybe rivera is suffering from that same
fatigue and he'd rather just move on
with a new quarterback too
yeah and maybe ron rivera just doesn't
know what cam is anymore
also so you know in the one team mike
we've been talking about it obviously is
the chargers you know if they continue
to fall off a cliff the rest of this
season i don't think they're changing
coaches
but i do think they would be open to at
least considering cam newton what do the
chargers need
they need a billboard on the 405 in la
that's what they need they need some
reason to kind of get people
quasi-excited
and and so
in the star system that is los angeles
bringing in cam newton is probably
something that with some people anyway
would be a draw
you are absolutely right and that may be
the smartest thing you've ever said
because i agree with it completely and
it seems like nobody else gets it it's
it's the it's look he's an icon and an
entertainer remember when he told you
that all those years ago this is what la
needs if you are the chargers and you
want to compete with the rams and you
want to compete in that market cam
newton is who you need i think the
charge is at the top of the list for cam
newton destinations if carolina doesn't
want him check us out for more pft ot
videos throughout the year
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports